Oh Walter here okay
Walter put down the window gone buddy
good yeah first thing he does is put
down the window and like stick his head
out
thank you good boy one of my Christmas
presents to my niece is that she can put
as much makeup on me as she wants and
we're gonna make you look gorgeous
this is when it starts you get really
goofy I don't doubt the darkness and
samba
I didn't realize my kitchen treasures a
casa su a champion dog ha what do you do
ah what's the paw what the hell is that
what your mom did your grandpa make a
rumor that's the final ocean boo no fees
for years for whites mom stop nice one
of my presents to my nephew Dylan was
this exciting guitar when you guys just
started reading my Wikipedia page I got
uncomfortable but what what's going on
with it then let's not must be out there
so much BS what's this about we lived in
Uganda according to this we lived in
Uganda for two years it's a nice day for
Cirque de Soleil
amalouna maybe the greatest Cirque du
Soleil show of all time
so it's New Year's Day and I'm in a
fancy car taking me to the airport to
fly to Austria I'm doing ski jump
slaloms luge bobsled so this will be my
home for the next six weeks a lot of
comments about that check out mr.
organized over here
I'm ready yeah you're a World Cup
winning team captain English rugby
player yes
ha ha red and John Allen you're you're a
triple medal winning Paralympian yes
four on the bike here three silvers in
London yeah these are my competitors
least them and I remember some [ __ ] I
haven't had any fresh powder along
it's my third day of snowboarding ever
damn shred
I just can't take it anymore she won't
break you man
you know you're working with British
people when you have 1,150 teabags
and look who made it to Austria
maybe we'll go for a ride all right here
they were an usher you can just like
legally steal a car oh what's the deal
crazy like this our speed limit so I
think we're on the Autobahn I think that
that's German fur goes fast I don't know
what city we're in for outdoors right
here froze good [ __ ] sweet mission
Don we miss with a good car we had it
where I find a [ __ ] schmuck around
here oh yeah come on with the deal this
is my thank you for watching my second
channel and look at this ah
grab yourself one of those and if you
haven't already subscribe and don't
think for one second that I forgot about
the skateboard bonanza we're just
finishing it up when I get home from
Austria you